So tonight is the second, uh, 2020 democratic
primary debate for the presidential initial
nomination in 2020.
Still so many candidates that it's going to
be divided up into two nights.
Tonight is night one, tomorrow night is night
two.
I will be streaming live commentary of both
nights on Youtube.
Hopefully you never know with these things
how aggressive the network broadcasting the
debate will be about copyright and, uh, it's
possible that they will shut down my stream
after five minutes.
I don't know.
Uh, but I hope you'll join me in any case
for as long as it goes on at youtube.com/the
David Pakman show.
We will do pre debate discussion with the
audience.
I will do live commentary on the debate, not
too much, just the right amount.
And then maybe we will open the phone lines
after and hear from people.
This is going to be quite frankly, the last
debate for a number of the Democratic candidates.
Tonight's debate is on CNN 8:00 PM eastern
time.
Just like tomorrow night's debate.
The polling and the fundraising requirements
are going way up between now, between the
second debate and the third debate, which
is going to be in September.
More on that in a second.
So first of all, let's go back to the first
debate.
Who was helped or hurt by that first debate?
Let's look at polling the day before debate
one and today to see how things have changed
since then.
Uh, the first debate, uh, was on June 26 and
27 so we'll look at polling from June 25th
and then we will look at polling from today.
And what you will notice is that Joe Biden
is basically unchanged.
Bernie Sanders is down a couple of points.
Elizabeth Warren is up a couple of points.
Kamala Harris is up four points from before
the first debate.
Pete Buddha judged down about a point better
or work down about a point.
Cory booker down a bit.
Andrew Yang up a point and then a bunch of
the Zeros and ones, they're all kind of like
within the margin of error.
And none of them have really changed.
I'm not even including all of the Zeros and
ones just for space purposes, but the headlines
are that between the first debate and the
second the only substantive changes are Kahmilah.
Harris is up for remaining the big winner
from the debate, although her polling numbers
have come down from where they peaked after
that first debate.
Elizabeth Warren up a couple of points.
Biden basically even in the end he declined
after the first debate but now has come back
up and Bernie Sanders down a couple of points.
Now we can argue about which polls are included.
I'm using the real clear politics averages
on the dates before each of these debates.
This is more or less the picture.
No major changes other than Kahmilah Harris
who spiked big but then came back down to
planet earth.
So tonight I doubt that we are going to see
much substance as usual because the format
just doesn't allow it.
These debates are not.
Listen, if you wanted to really learn the
most depth and detail about the positions
of the candidates, you would have a completely
different setup with 10 people on stage at
nevermind 20 obviously not having 20 on stage
is the right decision.
Even with 10 people on stage and these short
answers and sporadic, even shorter rebuttals,
you're just not going to learn a lot about
the candidates.
So we are likely to see candidates bring these
sort of planned gotcha moments to the table
like Camila Harris did with Joe Biden in that
first debate because unfortunately this is
the way to actually make an impact in the
debate.
So I'm going to be watching again given that
the debate format is so, uh, not conducive
to depth.
I will be watching for, do any candidates
have those types of Gotcha moments that will
cause substantive changes to the leaderboard.
For the third debate, which is in September,
September 12th and 13th tentatively still
scheduled for two nights, but may end up only
being one.
The requirements get strict or candidates
will need both, at least 2% in four polls
from an approved list of polls.
And we'll need 130,000 unique donors.
You need at least 400 donors from each of
at least 20 states.
So if we applied that standard today, there
would only be eight candidates remaining in
the next debate, meaning that they can consolidate
to just one night.
If the debate three requirements were applied
tonight, the only candidates remaining would
be Biden booted, Judge Harris, Bernie Sanders,
Elizabeth Warren, Cory booker, Beto O'Rourke,
and yes, Andrew Yang for me, the most interesting
thing, you all know that I've been interviewing
Andrew Yang before anybody was interviewing
him or almost anyone.
And uh, we have been talking about what is
his path forward because after, in the immediate
aftermath of that first debate didn't really
get much of a bump.
As it turns out, Andrew Yang as of today,
if we applied to the third debate, standards
would be one of the eight candidates remaining.
Castro would be out, Amy Klobuchar would be
out, Tom Stier would obviously be out Tulsi
gabard would be out, Hickenlooper, Williamson,
n's league, Ravel, they would all be out.
But Andrew Yang would be in with those final
eight.
If we applied those standards today.
So that is very, very interesting.
We have to consider tonight the kind of last
chance, last ditch effort for at least some
people.
What will you be looking for tonight?
Let me know.
Who Do you think has an opportunity to really
climb in the polls?
Last time nobody emailed me and said, I believe
Kamala Harris is the one who's going to spike.
People were talking about, I could be booted,
judge.
It could be Gabard, it could be Yang.
Most of that didn't happen.
Uh, Andrew Yang actually getting up to 2.3%
what are you looking for tonight?
Let me know and I hope that you will join
me live for coverage of the debates for as
long as CNN allows it on our youtube channel,
youtube.com/the David Pakman show.